good morning Hank it's Tuesday so when I
was in Jordan we drove out from Amman
one day to visit the Sabri refugee camp
just south of the Syrian border Sadri is
currently home to about eighty thousand
refugees most of whom are children first
I met these three teenage boys who were
taking a photography class taught by
refugee volunteers the youngest of them
15 year old Obie told me he had dropped
out of school to work but was now taking
the photography class because he missed
learning when I asked him about his
biggest fear he said what worries me
most is child labor this generation will
not be able to help Syria afterwards we
will become year by year more illiterate
I heard this again and again from
parents and kids alike the economic
pressures on refugees are so immense
that it's extremely difficult to keep
kids in school a problem made worse by
the school's being low fully underfunded
and overcrowded like kids up to attend
class in two shifts so they only get a
few hours of instruction per day and
each classroom often has over a hundred
kids in it I then met ADA's family she
lives with five of her kids in the camp
including twin five-year-olds who found
snapchat filters absolutely hilarious
when I asked ADA why she came to Jordan
she said very matter-of-factly I want
you to picture yourself sitting in your
home and an explosive barrel falls on
top of your roof and after the fog is
gone you check your kids to see if they
are alive and you find pieces of flesh
lying in your house and you have to
check to see if they are from your
family of course I can't picture that
not really I mean I can try to imagine
the horrors of war the trauma of
dislocation but I don't really know what
it's like to be a 13 year old whose
house gets bombed I don't know what it's
like to end up living in a single room
with my mother and four of my siblings
attending overcrowded schools with a
totally unfamiliar curriculum until
dropping out to earn $3 a day you can't
imagine those things but still I think
we need to know that they are real and
that this is happening but it's not all
that's happening because Autry is also
teaming with vibrance and life in the
main market place you can buy TVs and
solar phone chargers you can rent a
wedding dress and get your bicycles and
shoes fixed there's a pizza restaurant
that delivers and the pizza is
phenomenally good like better than any
delivered pizza in Indianapolis people
are complex and their lives are complex
and again and again I heard from
refugees that among their biggest
challenges is feeling dehumanized
feeling distrusted and disbelieved and
like much of the world sees them simply
as objects to be pitied or feared later
that day I visited with a family who's
18 year old daughter was about to begin
University
her father Musa Muhammad was immensely
proud of his daughter's achievements he
told me that in Syria they lived in a
two-story house they'd had a car now
they had only the hope of their
children's education and when I asked
him what he would say to people in the
US and Europe he answered only that
refugees are people and that being a
refugee does not distinguish me from any
other human being after saying goodbye
to Musa Mohammad and his family we went
outside and I saw a flock of pigeons
flying above me and I thought what an
improbable moment of natural beauty but
then someone explained to me that kids
train groups of pigeons like this one to
fly in elaborate patterns this beauty
wasn't some accident of nature it was a
kid's expression of joy we think this
horror is unfortunate but we can't fix
it it's human nature we think we need to
protect ourselves however we define
ourselves even if it means treating them
however we define them as less than
fully human we think well that's just
the nature of things but being in Xan
tree reminded me that human nature is
not just some force acting upon me human
nature is also something we are creating
together as we decide how to treat each
other in the world we share Hank I'll
see you on Friday